Je suis juste venu dire au revoir
malade je ne veux pas désolé de savoir
juste lui dire que tu aimes ses chaussures alors tu
veux que je t'appelle papa ou devrais-je
t'appeler Ethan c'est pour moi
ouais c'est tellement violet ouais c'est ta
couleur préférée  et c'était comme
neuf
ne penses-tu pas que Zoey mérite d'avoir
son papa pendant plus que
quelques mois de soirée je veux que tu viennes
travailler pour moi en échange de tes
services de nettoyage je pourrais t'offrir un
médicament expérimental qu'ils pourraient juste donner
toi ta petite question de retour de vie est
tuer ou mourir as tu fini de travailler pourquoi
m'as tu laissé seul alors que j'ai beaucoup voyagé
ma chérie
pourquoi tu as mis si longtemps à
revenir donc rien à voir avec toi
j'ai fait des choses impossibles  pour
expliquer que
tu penses que papa va rester aussi
longtemps qu'il le pourra ma chérie